[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos le
récit de la vie des acteurs économiques
du territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
nous sommes au siège social de la banque
populaire val de france situé à montigny
le bretonneux
le secteur bancaire a participé à la
résistance face à la crise sanitaire et
économique avec le rôle des banques dans
la distribution des prêts garantis par
l'état pour soutenir les entreprises en
difficulté face à la relance les banques
s'engagent aussi avec le prêt
participatif
c'est ce que vous allez découvrir dans
ce quatorzième numéro du sky échos lancé
il y a un nom les prêts garantis par
l'état ont permis aux entreprises de
faire face à la crise aujourd'hui les
banques accompagnent les sociétés pour
gérer le pg e avant de lancer un nouveau
dispositif destiné à la relance le prêt
participatif l'entrepreneuriat pour tous
c'est la volonté est l'objectif du
partenariat entre 50 et en yvelines
elle était terminée cette association
accompagne des porteurs de projets issus
des quartiers prioritaires pour créer
leur entreprise avec les nouvelles
mesures annoncées par le président de la
république les aides économiques aux
entreprises sont toujours d'actualité la
jeunesse aussi est accompagné dans cette
crise le point sur les dispositifs
existants l'entrepreneuriat pour tous et
sur cette voie que s'engage un
partenariat entre saint quentin en
yvelines et l'association les déterminer
le principe identifiées quinze porteurs
de projets pour les former et les
accompagner sur cinq mois dans le
lancement de leurs activités
entrepreunariales ou dans la création de
leur entreprise
les détails avec nadir gaguie c'est le
référent de cette association sur le
territoire
[Musique]
les déterminer une association qui a été
créée donc en 2015 par le président
fondateur moussa camara qui a pour but
principal de démocratiser
l'entrepreneuriat dans le quartier
prioritaire dans un premier temps est
justement de pouvoir de penser à travers
un programme d'accompagnement complet
une offre de formation à destination de
ses porteurs de projet dans le quartier
il y a des talents plus globalement dans
tous les domaines mais notamment dans la
crypte dans la création dans la
dynamique de développement économique
donc effectivement ce qu'on se dit c'est
que nous avons nous aussi eu des
parcours d'entrepreneurs ou n'a pas été
simple ça pas été content ça a été
plutôt compliqué non pas pour des
raisons d'argent mais par des ondes et
les noms de code et de réseaux est
l'objectif effectivement c'est te dire
que si on a la possibilité d'apporter
une main tendue à ces entrepreneurs à
ses porteurs de projets ces femmes et
ces hommes de ces territoires
on le fait avec grand plaisir et ça
participera activement au développement
économique aussi de tous ces territoires
[Musique]
trois semaines intensives qui vont nous
permettre justement de travailler sur le
potentiel du panther et de la porteuse
de projets l'idée cette formaliser le
projet de le structurer via
l'intelligence collective de aussi se
tirer tous les uns envers les autres et
bien évidemment de t'être en totale
adéquation avec la personne que nous
sommes et sont creusées et ensuite on va
pendant les cinq mois qui suivent avec
les partenaires de sa cote en yvelines
justement une carence cube accompagner
ces porteurs de projets sur les blocs de
compétences spécifiques à
l'entrepreneuriat l'étude de marché le
business plan le business model la
stratégie de communication stratégiques
comme un marketing comment elle est
recherchée un premier client la levée de
fonds tous ces sujets qui sont
extrêmement importants et primordiaux
pour pouvoir être outil un maximum dans
ce rôle de chef d'entreprise et si vous
êtes intéressés par cette démarche
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
face à l'incertitude sanitaires et
économiques l'état et les collectivités
s'engagent auprès des entreprises
l'administration se mobilisent aussi
auprès de la jeunesse
les détails dans ce décryptage
[Musique]
d
une cinquantaine d'entreprises ont
participé ali job dating organisé par
saint quentin en yvelines parmi ces
sociétés la banque populaire val de
france implanté ici à montigny le
bretonneux et pour parler de la
politique de recrutement de la banque
populaire val de france sur le
territoire des yvelines et sur saint
quentin en yvelines nous sommes avec
emilie wc une bâche leur bonjour bravo
nicolas vous êtes responsable ressources
humaines à la banque populaire val de
france alors pourquoi vous avez décidé
de participer à cette idée job dating
organisé par saint quentin en yvelines
alors on a décidé de participer à cette
job dating pour montrer que la banque
populaire val de france et une fois de
plus présentes sur le territoire et aux
événements de recrutement qui nous sont
chères alors c'est un unis job dating
dédié à l'alternance
l'alternance c'est quelque chose
d'important pour votre société
oui c'est c'est une entrée en la matière
en tout cas il ya un point d'entrée dans
l'entreprise qui est très important pour
nous on recrute tous les ans des
alternances sur l'ensemble de notre
territoire dont clerval de france
environ 80 et pour parler un petit peu
des yvelines on va on va recruter tous
les ans à peu près une quinzaine
d'alternants sur dans nos agences quel
type d'offre sur quel type de poste sur
des postes de conseiller accueil mais
aussi de conseiller clientèle
particuliers et puis là c'est plutôt pop
dans le cadre de licence mais après on
va aussi garder des alternants qu'on
fait leur bts ou leurs licences chez
nous et qu'on va accompagner sur des
métiers d'expertisés comme le
professionnel ou le patrimonial alors ça
c'était pour parler de l'alternance mais
maintenant sur les offres d'emploi
qu'est ce que vous proposez aujourd'hui
alors à la banque lui à val de france et
particulièrement sur le territoire dès
qu'on appelle yvelines versailles qui
est composé d'une quarantaine d'agencés
et 240 collaborateurs parler vraiment de
ce territoire
on va recruter sur toutes les filières
métiers dans notre réseau d'agents ce
donc du conseiller accueil ou
conséquents tels particulier du
conséquente elle privée conséquents tels
professionnels et des directeurs
d'agencé aussi voilà on a une population
très riche d'hommes et de femmes qui
demandent aussi à accueillir de futurs
collaborateurs de futurs collègues
donc on vous attend vous rechercher des
profils qualifiés des personnes qui
n'ont pas d'expérience dans le milieu
bancaire
les deux les deux parce que aujourd'hui
on a effectivement besoin d'eux
deux profils expérimentés pour rejoindre
notre réseau d'agents ce pour autant
c'est que la banque populaire val de
france est aussi une très très bonne
école pour apprendre le métier de
conseiller métier de banquier de plein
exercice
donc il nous arrive aussi très
régulièrement d'accueillir de jeunes
collaborateurs issus d'autres d'autres
secteurs et qui vont intégrer nos
agences pourra prendre pas à pas le
métier et évoluent au fur et à mesure
parce qu'on a aussi des parcours de
formation qui le permet c'est ça
l'évolution aussi que justement j'avais
voulu poser la question quelles sont les
perspectives d'évolution après les
perspectives sont aussi est très
majoritairement sur nos métiers de
commerciaux donc sur des métiers
d'expertisé sur du professionnel qui est
un peu réclamant l'adn des banque
populaire val de france mais aussi sur
des métiers de conseil qu'un tel privé
les conseillers en gestion de patrimoine
et métiers de direction d' agences on a
des perspectives
merci émis vers 9h heure merci nicolas
responsable ressources humaines à la
banque populaire val de france et
maintenant on va aller parler pge est
prêt participatif avec olivier -
regardez
[Musique]
les banques ont eu un rôle essentiel
dans le déploiement du prêt garanti par
l'état ce dispositif lancé il ya un an
par le gouvernement pour faire face à la
crise sanitaire dans les yvelines
plus de onze mille entreprises ont
bénéficié de 2,2 milliards d'euros pour
en parler nous sommes avec olivier -
directeur des marchés professionnels et
des entreprises à la banque populaire
val de france bonjour bonjour nicolas
[Musique]
quel bilan faites vous du prêt garanti
par l'état alors plusieurs éléments de
réponse
tout d'abord des pg e ont été mis en
place dans tout type d'entreprise
des grands des petits des dans tout
secteur d'activité aujourd'hui un an
après son lancement
nous pouvons constater que 90 % des
bénéficiaires sont principalement des
professionnels et des tpe issus du
secteur du commerce pour environ 22%
chez nous et du secteur de l'hôtellerie
restauration
avec les levées de man ciel en plus pour
environ 17%
les secteurs les plus frappés par la
crise à nîmes exactement aujourd'hui les
entreprises sont confrontées à un choix
à faire entre le remboursement ou
l'amortissement ou le report encore d'un
an pour amortir qu'est ce que vous
constatez aujourd'hui sur le terrain
alors aujourd'hui près de 50 % de
clients ont opéré leur choix de sorties
alors sans surprise ils ont opté à la
retraite grande majorité environ 95%
pour un amortissement dans sa durée la
plus longue dans la plupart des cas on
peut aussi noter pour ses clients qui
ont choisi l'amortissement que trois sur
quatre ont saisi l'opportunité d'un
différé supplémentaires d'amortissement
du capital pendant un an
ça s'explique du fait de l'incertitude
économique aux grecs te ment non
initialement lorsqu'on avait lancé le
pge l'on pensait sortir au courant de
l'été 2020 puis ensuite à fin d'année
2020 mais non nous sommes encore dans la
période du pge donc face à tester titude
qui se renouvelle régulièrement les
chefs d'entreprise ont la sagesse
d'avoir des mesures assez conservatoire
du conserver le plus possible empêcher
ce qui est rassurant aussi c'est que
aujourd'hui les chefs d'entreprise n'ont
pas utilisé la totalité de leurs prêts
en fait c'est conserver dans les
trésoreries
c'est effectivement au 6e
ce qu'on constate près de 50% des
pêcheurs qui ont été débloqués n'ont pas
été utilisés par la chef d'entreprise
mais sont conservés pour autant dans la
rue pour préparer la phase de relance et
de sortie de la crise sanitaire
alors justement la relance le
gouvernement souhaite la préparer et
l'accélérer avec un nouveau dispositif
le prêt participatif
en quoi consiste ce dispositif alors
effectivement je crois qu'il faut
rappeler ce qu'est la particularité d'un
presse participative c'est les sommes
issues de ce dispositif sont tassés mais
la bhl à des quasi-fonds propres
c'est-à-dire à ceux et yves allant à ce
amenez vos capitaux a mené par les
actionnaires
ils vont donc renforcer la structure
financière des entreprises
les entreprises elles vont utiliser
comment ce prêt participatif bas ce prêt
participative à les aider à construire
les conditions de relance en répondant à
des besoins qui ne trouvent pas
forcément actuellement des réponses
adaptées
ça va notamment leur permettre de pour
celles qui n'ont pas un accès direct aux
marchés financiers et aussi permettre à
ceux qui ne souhaitent pas modifié la
gouvernance de l'entreprise de
bénéficier de capitaux l'on est stable
pour quels types d'investissements on
peut imaginer alors ça va être bien
entendu tous les types d'investissements
qui vont aider à la relance à cette
sortie de crise
bien sûr tous les projets d'innovation
de transformation digitale de transition
et énergétiques et tout investissements
nécessaires à la pérennisation de leur
activité merci olivier - merci je le
rappelle directeur des marchés des
professionnels et des entreprises à la
banque populaire val de france et c'est
avec vous que se conclut ce numéro du
sky et kuro merci de l'avoir suivi
émission à revoir en replay sur notre
site internet ou sur l'application
mobile
à bientôt sur tv 70
[Musique]
m